[Musique]
impeccable et notre invité politique ce
matin c'est BR sortefeu bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous BR sortefeu
députés européens membres des
républicains enin ministre de
l'intérieur on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
bonjour Julien de la voie du Nord
bonjour bonjour on va parler pr sorte
feu de la situation en Israël d'abord
Emmanuel Macron qui reçoit aujourd'hui
les chefs de parti et qui va prendre la
parole ce soir à 20h lors d'une
allocution qu'est-ce que vous en
attendez d'abord c'est c'est normal dans
une démocratie moderne que le chef de
l'État reçoive les responsable des
formations politiques encore une fois
don le rôle est reconnu par la
Constitution he c'est l'article 6 donc
c'est c'est tout à fait sain même si
évidemment nous nous trouvons dans une
situation un peu particulière puisque
l'ensemble des familles politiques que
s'est exprimé s'est exprimé avec
sincérité avec justesse avec Solidarité
toutes toutes sauf une donc ca
évidemment la France insoumise et
conduite par Jean-Luc Mélenchon et donc
naturellement ça donne une tonalité un
peu particulière à cette rencontre mais
est-ce qu'il faut que le Président de la
République rassure les les les Français
sur les risques d'importation du du
conflit en
France le président de la ré publuique
sera j'imagine trouver les mots pour
définir ce que nous vivons l'horreur que
nous observons il trouvera les mots pour
dire que
l'objectif c'est la destruction d'Israël
c'est la haine du Juif c'est la
détestation de la démocratie c'est le
rejet de l'Occident et j'en suis
convaincu et j'en suis convaincu que
c'est un combat contre la civilisation
et l'histoire nous rappelle c'est ce que
je pense qu'il faut souligner comme
message auprès de la population
française européenne et mondial
d'ailleurs c'est que quand il y a un
combat contre la
civilisation les civilisés finissent
toujours par battre les Barbar une Guer
CIV sel vous je pense que l'attitude du
Hamas aujourd'hui c'est un combat oui au
bout du compte additionnant tout ce que
je viens de rappeler c'est un combat
contre la civilisation mais du coup
qu'est-ce que vous entendez que va dire
qu'est-ce qu'il va demander au président
de la République ah je pense qu'il va
euh exprimer avec ses mots avec son
expérience avec son tempérement ce que
je viens de ce que je viens de vous
rappeler mais la question que vous me
posiez qui est une question essentielle
c'est celle de l'importation h vous
savez le le ministère de l'Intérieur a
donné des chiffres qui sont ailleurs
impressionnants puisque sur de jours
quelques jours I 2 jours et une
cinquantaine d'actes antisémites mais on
a on connaît la la réalité
des actes antireligieux dans notre pays
la dernière année je vous le rappelle la
dernière année connue c'est
1589 actes antireligieux et
antichrétien
589 antisémit et 213 antimusulman c'est
ça la réalité alors vous dire mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez démontrer par
par là je veux simplement rappeler que
la population juive qui était
extraordinairement minoritaire notre
pays M pas 1 % et et bien elle est
victime à 35 % en quelque sorte dans les
actes antireligieux c'est les actes
antijuifs représente 35 % du total mais
est-ce que aujourd'hui vous êtes inquiet
pour la sécurité des Juifs de France
bien sûr bien sûr et il y a
naturellement des mesures techniques que
le ministre l'Intérieur a a prise et que
tout ministre de l'Intérieur aurait pris
à sa place de la même manière avec la
sécurisation d'un notamment des lieux de
culte pas simplement les les mosquées il
y a des espaces cultuels euh qui sont
aussi à protéger enfin bref ça mobilise
naturellement les effectif est est-ce
que le ministre de de de l'intérieur
doit euh et le gouvernement doit taper
du point sur la table notamment
vis-à-vis des des mouvements qui
pourrait soutenir officiellement le la
la je mets des guillemets résistance
palestinienne qui à à bouter le feu et à
à accentuer les les le risque de de
violence par tempérament et par
expérience et je pense que toute
complaisance sera compris comme une
faiblesse c'est vrai sur ce sujet mais
c'est vrai sur bien d'autres sujets et
donc il faut agir immédiatement avec la
plus grande fermeté c'est-à-dire que
s'il y a entre guillemets des dérapages
par exemple en milieu scolaire il faut
immédiatement saisir le pro procureur de
la République il faut que il y ait une
réaction qui soit immédiate parce que
c'est vrai que il y a des risques
d'inflammation mais pas pardon de de le
dire c'est pas simplement dans notre
pays c'est dans un certain nombre de
pays européens et je ne sais pas et vous
non plus par définition je ne sais pas
quelles seront les réactions dans les
jours qui
viennent dans les rues en
Égypte aux Émirats en Jordanie et ainsi
de suite donc on ne sait pas ça touche
c'est pas simplement un problème
francilien c'est pas un problème
français c'est pas simplement un
problème européen c'est un problème qui
touche une grande partie du monde donc
il faut aucune complaisance mais sur la
la condamnation aussi vis-à-vis des des
partis politiques parce que c'était
aussi un peu la la question duen votre
collègue par exemple sénateur Stéphane
lerulier il appelle à dissoudre la
France insoumise vous allez jusque là
vous il y a des critères de dissolution
donc ceuxci doivent être appliqués si
mais est-ce que pour vous il faut
dissoudre la France insoumison
en tout cas les propos de la France
insoumis sont totalement inacceptables
et je dois reconnaître que comme tous
les Français qui regardent cela j'ai les
yeux exorbités eu quand j'entends la
présidente du groupe à l'Assemblée euh
madame Panau euh refuser de dire
clairement les choses bon à savoir que
c'est une organisation terroriste qui a
agressé Israël ne pas reconnaître cela
c'est quand même
euh ça nécessite quand même de réfléchir
pourquoi
pourquoi j'essaie toujours moi dans dans
ma vie sans doute comme vous j'essaie
toujours de me mettre à la place de
interlocuteurs et là je me dis quelle
est la raison pour laquelle si la France
ins soumise adopte cette position enité
je crois qu'il y en a
deux la première c'est par un calcul
électoral et c'est un cynisme si c'est
le cas c'est un cynisme honteux et
lamentable et deuxième possibilité c'est
une conviction
sincère bah c'est dans ces cas-là une
lourde erreur tragique donc soit il y a
d'un côté un cinisme honteux et
lamentable soit de l'autre côté une l
lourde erreur tragique mais dans les
deux cas c'est honnêtement ça ne fait
pas grandir la démocratie il y a pas une
forme d'antisémitisme selon vous ça fait
pas partie des explications pour vous
dans les racines de tout cela il doit y
avoir bien sûr des formes
d'antisémitisme
mais au-delin comme je vous l'ai dit au
début je je ne change pas d'avis c'est
bien sûr contre Israël bien sûr contre
le peuple juif la haine du peuple juif
mais encore une fois ça va bien au-delà
c'est d'abord le peuple juif mais ça va
bien au-delà à contrario la la gauche
accuse le gouvernement de faire le jeu
du gouvernement de de Benjamin netanahou
de s'aligner sur sur ce sur sa sur sa
position sans sans nuance est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut retrouver une
voix de la France mesurer appeler un
cesser le feu rappeler que la poation de
la France c'est la création de de deux
états la voix de la France était
vraiment assez forte à l'heure
actuelle la voix de la
France vous me permettrez de le dire la
voix de la France est aujourd'hui un peu
éteinte éteinte où on est un peu à
Faun par le désastre je suis obligé de
de le dire de notre politique étrangère
moi je je m'en jou pas je le regrette et
je vous donne simplement ce qui est mon
mon expérience et j'aiété ministre de
l'Immigration puis ministre de
l'Intérieur et de l'Immigration et je me
rendais très très très régulièrement
dans cette première parti jeandais très
très régulièrement en Afrique on avait
j'avais de bonnes relations et le
président Sarkozy d'abord mais avec
président du Mali qui était à Manou
touani Touré j'avais des relations amis
avec ça n'a jamais été simple avec
Israël vous le savez Nicolas SAR en son
temps avait déjà eu des difficultés vous
me parlez de la politique étrangère de
la France je dis aujourd'hui je constate
hélas que nous sommes chassés d'espace
où nous étions où nous jouions un rôle
mais al comment rrouver cette et
concernant Israël bien sûr ça a été très
compliqué vous avez en mémoire les
déplac le déplacement de Jacques Chirac
le placement de Lionel Jospin et c'est
parce que c'est un sujet
extraordinairement sensible mais à un
moment donné vous savez il faut aller à
l'essentiel bien sûr que si on se pose
des questions à non plus finir on oublie
l'essentiel et aujourd'hui l'essentiel
c'est d'exprimer de avec force une
solidarité totale avec un état qui est
agressé par des terroristes c'est ça la
réal jusqu'où cette solidarité on voit
le gouvernement
israélien avec la volonté de d'écraser
le le Hamas qui à à on va dire à à user
de de moyens qui qui touchent les
population civile dans la ville de de
Gaza en Europe certains ont parlé de
suspension des des aides pour pour Gaza
qu'est-ce jusqu'où doit-on aller moi je
suis favorable à la suspension des aides
dont on n'a pas la certitude de la
destination voyez ce que je dis vous
mais vous le savez vous aujourd'hui o où
va l'argent de ces aides justement alors
les aides d'abord il faut savoir ce que
ça euh à quoi ça correspond premièrement
l'Union européenne est le premier
soutien financier euh sur cette sur ce
territoire deuxème élément c'est de
l'ordre ça c'est élevé puisque c'est
selon les calculs c'est pe c'est entre 1
milillard 2 et 1 milillard 7 sur la
période 2021- 2024 et il faut savoir que
sur ce volume la moitié a d'ors et déjà
été versé donc toute manière il reste en
réité 600 millions que l'on peut
suspendre c'est ce à quoi ça correspond
mais ce qui me préoccupe c'est que nous
avons maintenant parce que c'est avec le
recul un certain nombre d'éléments sur
l'utilisation de ces fonds et notamment
on a découvert que sur la période
précédente euh on avait financé à
hauteur de 18 millions euh l'université
Islam uneuniversité islamique chequ
Yassine dans lequel université on a
formé les dirigeant actuel du ramas donc
je dis je suis oui favorable à une
suspension des aides aide que dont on
n'est pas absolument certain de
l'utilisation et de la destination c'est
pas la position d'union européne ça ça
impose une pass euréne pour l'instant il
y a eu faut le reconnaître il y a eu un
cafouillage à la commission entre un
commissaire hongrois qui s'est exprimé
sans doute plus rapidement mais vous
m'interrogez je suis parlementaire
européen je vous dire moi je seraaiis
décideur sur ces sujets voilà ce que je
dirais il y a est-ce que ça on est sûr
que ça va à tel endroit pour soulager
aider mais est-ce que vous regrettez que
ça ne soit pas ce que l'Union européenne
dise pour le moment oui je le regrette
oui et si on ne sait pas on suspend h
est-ce que d'ailleurs la France comme
vous le savez est à hauteur de 95
millions et je pense que la France
devrait adopter aussi cette position on
ne connaît pas la l'utilisation finale
on ne verse pas on connaît l'utilisation
si c'est une solidarité alimentaire une
sur haute alors là on peut l'utiliser
est-ce que la France doit aussi
réfléchir à à la remise en cause de ces
liens diplomatiques avec le Qatar qui
est soupçonné de financer le la
Armas alors le Qatar comme vous savez
est un grand investisseur oui il
investit dans notre pays un peu plus de
25 milliards
d'euros nous ne sommes pas d'ailleurs
les seuls bien bien au contraire puisque
nous avons à peu pr la même proportion
d'investissement qatari en Allemagne et
en France donc les deux principales
puissances de l'Union européenn sont à
peu près égalité sur ce plan là et nous
nous trouvons et le Qatar investit
d'abord d'abord au Royaume-Uni donc si
on regarde le continent européen je dire
on est pas du tout une
exception deè élément le
Qatar peut-il être utile
on va le savoir très vite dans ce
conflit parce que le Qatar vous l'avez
observé dans si vous si vous regardez
son attitude au cours des dernières
décennies
s'efforce toujours de jouer un rôle de
médiateur ils essayent d'être médiateur
et sans doute voudront-ils jouer un rôle
dans la libération des otages donc nous
allons savoir je pense dans un délai
rapproché si le Qatar agit pour libérer
aider à la libération mais la Qatar
abrite aussi le chef du Hamas pour vous
il peut jouer le rôle de médiateur mais
c'est ce qui font depuis si vous
observez le leur histoire vous savez
c'est le le passé éclaire un peu le
présent si vous observez le rôle du
Qatar au cours de ces dernières années
je mets de côté l'aspect économique et
l'aspect financier tout temp d'ailleurs
pour vous il finance pas le Hamas le CAT
mais bien sûr que
finance donc la question c'est de savoir
est-ce qu'ils vont aider ou pas la
libération des otages je vous rappelle
que il y a tous les otages israéliens il
y a des 18 français il y a des
Américains et ainsi de suite est-ce
qu'il joue ce rôle ou pas après il
faudra certainement tirer un certain
nombre de leçons bon parallè on peut
quand même continuer à se comporter de
la même façon avec le pays qui finance
le Hamas avec un des pays qui finance
Hamas faudra il faudra dès lors que les
choses seront connues seront précisé il
faudra naturellement en tirer un certain
nombre de leçons lesquels justement
concernant le rôle du Qatar est-ce qu'il
était informé est-ce que il était
associé est-ce qu'il a financé
l'opération ce sont des questions que
l'on doit se poser mais pas d'ailleurs
vous me parlez du Qatar mais c'est pas
simplement vis-à-vis du Qatar c'est la
question vis-à-vis de l'Iran c'est la
question aussi vis-à-vis d' certain pas
de relation d'investissement et de
relation commercial avec c'est pour ça
que je vous dis
euh faudra tirer il faudra tirer un
certain nombre de leçons dès lors que
l'on saura la vérité total énergie a
signé un accord avec le Qatar un accord
pour un impr isionnement en gaz pendant
27 ans c'est un problème ça pour vous 2
c'est
une ce qui est un accord c'est l'accord
qui a été un accord un peu surprise
enfin on l'a découvert il y a quelques
heures et c'est un accord qui garantit
la livraison de 3 millions et demi
de gaz ton de gaz liquéfié et pendant
une durée longue c'est une certaine
stabilité pendant 27 ans c'est un accord
très important mais c'est sûr que la
concomitance du calendrier ne rend pas
cet accord particulièrement sympathique
bah c'est ça à ce stade on peut pas en
dire tellement plus mais tot à l'énergie
aurait pas dû signer pas à ce moment-là
en tout cas le calendrier visiblement
est mal tombé on a l'impression de
découvrir quelque chose et tout d'un
coup ça devient un problème comme le
souligne Orian mais finalement cette
relation du du Qatar avec des mouvements
islamiques n'est pas nouvelle vous
l'avez vous l'avez rappelé et pourtant
ça n'a jamais empêché chez la France
d'avoir des relations commerciales très
intenses avec de de vendre des armes
est-ce que pour vous ce n'est pas une
faute non mais c'est ne parlez pas
simplement de la France en l'occurrence
parce que je vous rappelle que ce que je
viens de vous dire c'est-à-dire que ça
concerne de nombreux pays européens et
notamment les la première puissance
européenne qui elle-même accueille des
investissements massifs du Qatar s'il y
a une réaction à avoir je pense qu'elle
doit être concertée avec les pays que je
viens de citer donc à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne selon vous on va
passer à un autre sujet Julien on parle
du texe immigration oui qui est toujours
en négociation mais cela dit il y a eu
des avancées géralman ministre le
ministre de l'Intérieur dans un courrier
au président LR de la commission des
lois François Noël buffet s dit disposé
à soutenir la quasi intégralité des
proposition faite par la la dite
commission on évoque il évoque Gerin un
durcissement des conditions de
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers de en tension hein c'est la
fameuse ligne ligne rouge qui avait été
tracée par LR la mise en œuvre d'une po
du séjour un débat obligatoire annuel
sur les chiffres de de l'immigration je
vous en passe est-ce que dans ces
conditions LR peut toper là avec le
ministre non mais on a on verra à
l'arrivée de la
discussion il y a à mon sens je suis pas
sénateur ni à l'Assemblée nationale mais
à mon sens il y a effectivement des
points durs bon et parmi les points durs
il y a notamment la nécessité de
réformer l'aide médicale d'État
comme vous le savez ça augmenté de 134 %
bon ben là il vous dit oui g il y a la
nécessité de de la réformer c'est un
élément très important puisqu'il y a en
rité une dérive de l'utilisation de ce
dispositif je vous rappelle que
d'ailleurs nous sommes les derniers en
Europe à avoir un dispositif de cette
nature je parle de l'aide médicale
d'État puisque la plupart des il y a des
aides médicales pour les étrangers dans
les autres pays européens il y a
précisément vous avez raison et il y a
en rité dans un certain nombre de pays
européens des aides d'urgence oui pas le
même système pas le même fonctionnement
que l'aide médicale d'État en France
c'est pour ça qu'il y a une différence
et il y a la question des mineurs isolés
il y a la question très importante de la
régularisation je vous dis j'ai été
ministre de l'Immigration et ministre de
l'Intérieur et l'immigration là aussi
j'ai appris une chose et personne ne
pourra me démontrer le contraire c'est
que euh si on décide une régularisation
systématique cela crée
inéluctablement un appel d'air mais
c'est pas ce que dit c'est pas dit le
texte c'est pas ce que dit gerérald
Herman il parle pas de régularisation
systématique si dans la pratique ça
aboutissait à ça quand on dit métier en
tenstion et hop on y va ça veut dire ça
il y quand même des
conditions des ce sont des tyes de
séjour j'allais dire qu'ils ont
tellement restreint les conditions que
finalement ça va probablement conc une
dizaine de milliers de personnes mais
c'est là où vous vous trompez c'est qu'à
partir du moment où ça se sait et bien
cela crée l'appel d'air vous vous partez
d'un petit chiffre et vous aboutissez à
des régularisations beaucoup plus larges
il fa avoir pass un temp en France
malgré malgré malgré les gages donnés
par le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
dites toujours c'est impossible dans
l'état je vous dis à titre personnel
puisque je ne suis pas sénateur je vous
dis tant qu'il n'y a pas de
clarification sur ce point cela me
paraît difficile d'approuver ce texte et
de manière plus générale je je ne veux
entendre de la bouche du gouvernement
une position claire est-ce que l'on veut
plus
d'immigration moins d'immigration ou la
même immigration qu'aujourd'hui ça je ne
l'entends pas je seraiis aujourd'hui
ministre de l'Intérieur et de
l'Immigration je diraiis clairement les
choses je dirais l'année dernière on a
délivré
3300300 titres 300 oui c'est ça
33300 titres de ses jours c'est le
chiffre le plus important de notre
histoire jamais il n'y a eu sur notre
territoire autant d'étrangers il y avait
7 % de la population qui était étrangère
en 2000 est on est monté à 10,3 et bien
je je dirais il faut faire baisser
l'immigration dans notre pays
par est-ce que vous avez entendu
non non non non est-ce que vous avez
entendu je suis heureux voyez l'avocate
comme ça ça per du ministère du
ministère de l'Intérieur je F je vous
félicite de cette nouvelle activité
c'est clair il dit qu'il faut durcir les
règles non non est-ce que vous AZ est-ce
que vous avez entendu dire il faut faire
baisser l'immigration de notre pays
est-ce que vous l'avez entendu est-ce
que vous l'avez lu est-ce que vous avez
écouté des responsables de la majorité
dire ça qui sontos notamment sur les
reconduites fr il dit que c'est le texte
le plus ferme de ces 20 dernières années
savez en politique là aussi ce que je
sais c'est qu'il faut dire les
choses clairement et agir
fort je vous le dis ce n'est pas clair
moi j'attends un responsable
gouvernemental que c'est surtout que
vous ne voulez pas entendre parce que
vous n'avez pas envie de voter ce texte
non ce que je ce don je n'ai pas envie
c'est que on continue sur ce rythme
d'accueil sur notre territoire de 450 à
nou n propositions aboutissent à faire
baisser l'immigration je peux le redire
dans
une pas toi
ver j'attends qu'on entend les mots
simples oui nous voulons faire
baisser je me permets de
relancer mais face à qui sont donnés par
le ministre de l'Intérieur en au moins
de bonne volonté visiblement de se
rapprocher de vos de vos conditions
est-ce que vous vous pouvez entendre que
la seule la seule réponse de LR soit on
votera une motion de censure si vous le
passez comme ça non moi je la position
de LR elle est très simple c'est
l'intérêt du pays et l'intérêt des
Français c'est ça la seule chose qui
compte moi tout le reste ça m'est
complètement t égal vous savez toutes
ces argus tout ça la réalité c'est je
pense qu'aujourd'hui dans dans notre
pays il y a une présence d'immigré trop
importante par rapport à la fois à notre
capacité d'intégration et à nos besoins
et donc il faut faire baisser
l'immigration et ne pas continuer à ce
rit de 450000 à 500000 entré chaque
année comprenez bien parce que c'est
c'est c'est comme ça qu' vous avez
l'équivalent chaque année de en gros la
ville de Lyon d'entrée
supplémentaire s un derni pas laissé
croire qu'il y a 500000 personnes qui
arrivent et puis y en a pas qui partent
combien il y en a qui partent et ben
dites-moi ben ben non mais dites-lemoi
par je suis j'ai pas été ministre de
l'intérieur ça n'a rien à voir c'est ça
n'a rien à voir quand vous avez 330000
titres de séjour je vous garantis que
vous avez pas 330000 départs un dernier
mot sur les européennes puisque vous
êtes députés européens pourquoi vous
désignez pas votre tête de liste
François Xavier bami c'est pas une
évidence je vais vous dire comme je
m'attendais un peu à votre question je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai regardé oui les
périodes dans lesquelles on choisit on
désigne les candidats ce n'est dans ma
famille
politique jamais avant février et la
plupart du temps c'est entre février et
mai donc comme ça vous
pourrezin c'est un petit peu tard ben un
mois c'est la temps de campagne ça c'est
fait mais pourquoi ne pas reconduire
franam si vous me demandez mon avis
personnel parce que ça par définition
c'est une décision collective François
Xavier l'ami a
acquis l'expérience au Parlement
européen il connaît maintenant
remarquablement les les rouages du
Parlement il a été un président de
délégation avec beaucoup d'efficacité et
en même temps il a cette hardardeur de
la jeunesse qui est aussi utile voilà
donc il de qualit l'expérience la
jeunesse le sérieux et puis je dirais le
talent et vous candidat et ben justement
je vous ai dit entre février et et mais
réviter comme ça vous pourrez me
réinviter voyez c'est un petit appel on
vous réinvitera re ent au février mais
du coup merci pr sortefeu merci d'avoir
été notre invité la une de la voie du
Nord Julien c'est les médecins vendredi
noir chez les médecins voilà c'est à
lire dans votre journal merci Julien à
la semaine prochaine merci brissortefeu
on passe au club des territoires